is how its brain coordinates this complex information
between the eyes and the wings
and turns hunting into a simple reflex.
To study this, Jaimie's been spending a lot of time
socializing with dragonflies.
What do you need to do your experiments?
Jaimie Spahr: First of all, you need dragonflies.
Oliver: I have a mesh cage to catch the dragonflies.
JS: The more I worked with them, the more terrified I got of them.
They're actually very scary, especially under a microscope.
They have really sharp mandibles, are generally pretty aggressive,
which I guess also helps them to be really good predators.
GG: In order to learn what's going on inside the dragonfly's brain
when it sees a prey,
we're going to eavesdrop in on a conversation
between the eyes and the wings,
and to do that, we need to anesthetize the dragonfly on ice
and make sure we protect its wings so that we can release it afterwards.
Now, the dragonfly's brain is made up of specialized cells called neurons
and these neurons are what allow the dragonfly
to see and move so quickly.
The individual neurons form circuits by connecting to each other
via long, tiny threads called axons
and the neurons communicate over these axons using electricity.
In the dragonfly, we're going to place little metal wires, or electrodes,
along the axon tracks,
and this is what's really cool.
In the dragonfly, there's only 16 neurons;
that's eight per eye
that tell the wings exactly where the target is.
We've placed the electrodes so that we can record from these neurons
that connect the eyes to the wings.
Whenever a message is being passed from the eye to the wing,
our electrode intercepts that conversation in the form of an electrical current,
and it amplifies it.
Now, we can both hear it and see it in the form of a spike,
which we also call an action potential.
Now let's listen in.
Right now, we have the dragonfly flipped upside down,
so he's looking down towards the ground.
We're going to take a prey, or what we sometimes call a target.
In this case, the target's going to be a fake fly.
We're going to move it into the dragonfly's sights.
(Buzzing)
Oh!
Oh, look at that.
Look at that, but it's only in one direction.
Oh, yes!
You don't see any spikes when I go forward,
but they're all when I come back.
In our experiments,
we were able to see that the neurons of the dragonfly
fired when we moved the target in one direction but not the other.
Now, why is that?
Remember when I said that the dragonfly
had near 360-degree vision.
Well, there's a section of the eye called the fovea
and this is the part that has the sharpest visual acuity,
and you can think of it as its crosshairs.
Remember when I told you the dragonfly had individual precise control of its wings?
When a dragonfly sees its prey, it trains its crosshairs on it
and along its axons it sends messages only to the neurons
that control the parts of the wings
that are needed to keep that dragonfly on target.
So if the prey is on the left of the dragonfly,
only the neurons that are tugging the wings to the left are fired.
And if the prey moves to the right of the dragonfly,
those same neurons are not needed, so they're going to remain quiet.
And the dragonfly speeds toward the prey
at a fixed angle that's communicated by this crosshairs to the wings,
and then boom, dinner.
Now, all this happens in a split second, and it's effortless for the dragonfly.
It's almost like a reflex.
And this whole incredibly efficient process is called fixation.
But there's one more story to this process.
We saw how the neurons respond to movements,
but how does the dragonfly know that something really is prey?
This is where size matters.
Let's show the dragonfly a series of dots.
Oh, yeah!
JS: Yeah, it prefers that one.
GG: Out of all the sizes,
we found that the dragonfly responded to smaller targets over larger ones.
In other words, the dragonfly was programmed to go after smaller flies
versus something much larger, like a bird.
And as soon as it recognizes something as prey,
that poor little fly only has seconds to live.
Today we got to see how the dragonfly's brain works
to make it a very efficient killer.
And let's be thankful that we didn't live 300 million years ago
when dragonflies were the size of cats.